Goldberg beginning the Hot Topic debate
by noting that Budweiser was her beer of
choice before she quit drinking oh
before she quit huh asked what
conservatives are so angry about beer is
not a Democrat or Republican it doesn't
have a belief system it's just beer
well uh I'll tell you I'll tell you it's
because Dylan Mulvaney is the embodiment
of what I call Elsa gate 2.0 the
algorithmic manipulation resulting in
chaotic nonsense content and then Bud
Light was like I got an idea let's fund
more of this Decay and promote booze to
children and so I'm just like bro
everything about what you're doing is a
bad thing but here's the best part the
VP of marketing for Budweiser admitted
their goal was to out Market alcohol to
kids she was like it's a it's an old
dying brand and we got to get young
people like oh is that what you're
saying because Dylan Mulvaney's audience
are like 15 years old you can just
Google it the average user of tick tock
is under 21. that's all that matters and
then obviously Del Mulvaney's audience
is not a bunch of 50 year old dudes